i remember we had this meeting
um
with a lot of our employees
and we were like look we got three
options we can die in two months
we can try to get to break even or we
can try to get this thing profitable
hello this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell and today we're going to talk
about whether your startup is default
alive or default debt so this is a
concept that was actually invented by
one of the co-founders of yc paul graham
dalton do you just want to start by
explaining what this means
yeah i mean so to start with you should
read his blog post it is excellent it is
short it is easy to read and so you
should read it but let me try to give
you my crash course in it
here's here's what he means by default
alive default dead
as founders
we we like to ignore the truth a lot of
the time and one of those truths are is
my startup going to go out of business
right
it's kind of an awkward thing to talk
about you know you don't want to bring
that up in polite company and so the
point of default default dead is it
forces you to be honest with yourself
if i don't raise any more money am i
gonna die am i out of business
or am i gonna make it
and default alive is different than
profitable profitable means today i make
enough money that i am profitable my
bank account grows every month you sell
with me default alive means i may be
burning money today but my growth rate
is high enough on revenue that i will
become profitable before my bank account
goes to zero
does that make sense and so if not a
single other dollar of investor money
comes into the business my growth rate
is high enough such that i don't have to
lose sleep that i'm gonna have to raise
a round before i die
and his point is this is a binary either
you are default alive or you are not
default alive thus default dead there's
no third option here friends
it forces you to pin yourself down in
your own mind right does that sound
right to you michael did i get that
right
you nailed it and and what's interesting
is that another yc co-founder trevo
blackwell basically made a calculator
that allows you to calculate this
because you know
i would argue it's easy to calculate but
it's just nice to have a tool there
where you could just input some numbers
and we'll make sure that's linked to as
well
so
i think that with this concept of
default debt or default alive
what's so weird is how obvious it is
like it's weirdly the kind of concept
that like the entrepreneur who runs a
barber shop will understand
before a startup founder well right it's
like
it's it's so logical what do you think
are some of the reasons why founders
have a hard time
understanding this is important math to
do like what what's what's distracting
them from this truth i think the context
is it if you've raised some money
say you're a yc company raise money demo
day
the belief that you'll be able to raise
more money
it's hard to not take that for granted
and you're like yeah yeah but but really
once you started raising money you get
hooked on it you know like you get
hooked on the juice okay and so the idea
that maybe you won't be able to raise
the next round or that'll go harder than
you want
to say that out loud is almost a showing
like it's like you're not confident
enough like i think you i think it's
awkward to speak of these things with
your co-founders with whoever because
it's almost like well of course you can
raise the next round like of course like
we're gonna make it
and so
i think it's that man i think i think
again we've both been founders i don't
think you want to say this stuff out
loud too much it makes it sound like
you're worried or scared and you
certainly would not want to admit this
to your investors
well i think that
here's the tricky bit in my mind not
only is it that
this idea of like well if we question
our ability to raise the next round are
we not confident or are we going to
psych some people out in our team and
make them not want to work here
it's that plus raising the next rounds
harder
so you kind of get screwed both ways
like
like i think oftentimes
founders believe that raising the next
round is going to be like the last round
even though they kind of understand that
the next round
there's a smaller pool of people who can
do it they're investing more money
so so
logically it should be harder right like
mathematically there are fewer
series a's than seed rounds and fewer
series b's and series
right and so but i don't think they
internalize that and one of the things
you talk about a lot in the yc batch is
this idea that
startups are series of mini games and
the minigames change and get harder i
think people weirdly think that this
fundraising minigame doesn't change
when of course it does look of course
and sometimes it's easier when you have
a great product and great design
sometimes your next round is far easier
to be clear yes we're not saying it's
always harder but and here's the big but
it's a moving target
and there's this thing called the
economy
yeah this is a thing called like
investors who are people that are not
within your control
we don't know interest rates
and so what you'll see is whenever
there's like choppy waters
the default dead people that we're
banking on the next round being easy
die simple as that okay
it's in the companies that are default
alive when there's choppy waters they
live
and i think it's funny because
i like your phrasing we can't tell you
whether it's going to be
harder or easier to raise your next
round we can just tell you it's probably
going to be different than the last one
so you should be planning for a wider
range of possibilities than same as last
time and i think about this in terms of
margin of error like last thing on the
screen yeah the margin of error when
your default alive is huge you can go
out
and try to raise around and fail
and be fine
there's huge margin for error and what's
funny i always talk about this
imagine if techcrunch wrote an article
about every failed fundraise
it'd be
that's yeah we're only reading about the
successful one there's lots of failed
fundraisers friends lots and lots and
lots and lots the majority of
fundraising the majority the vast
majority so i think the folks that are
just reading techcrunch
think
that most fundraisers succeed so you're
getting a really warped view and so so
again like bear with me so most of them
fail well guess what if your default
alive
all right like that's not good news that
your fundraise failed but you can live
to fight another day but if you're
running your business tight where you
have like three months of runway and
you're banking that it's gonna work and
it's you're running this thing super
tight
what happens if your fundraise doesn't
work is you die i think about default
live default ad is
if you actually control
if you're actually in control of your
company and not
outside parties i.e investors
actually hold the key to your company
you're kind of working for your
investors they're they're actually your
boss when your default's alive
you're the it's you're in control of
everything right yeah it's kind of
awesome it's a it's a question of agency
over the outcome you know
well in dalton we talk so much in the
batch about
leverage when it comes to fundraising
and when i think about being default to
live there's there's multiple levels of
leverage one
is confidence right if you don't need a
deal
man you're gonna pitch better like like
this that's the way life works like when
you don't need something you're way more
convincing than when you're begging for
something
um
and then two leverage being the investor
knows you don't need them so not only is
your pitch better right the investor
knows your business is stronger and
knows there's going to be more
competition to invest in your business
and therefore is more likely to want to
invest in your business so you get like
double leverage
whereas on the flip side if you run your
business default dead you take two
average hits like when you really think
deep down especially like you said when
you're on low runway you're like [ __ ] if
i don't threat this needle or this
fundraiser we're dead
a good investor can always tell
whether the company's pitching them is
going to die
and even if you want to invest
you offer worse terms or you put in
sneaky
you know there's all sorts of sneaky
things ratchet investors can do yeah
yeah
not good by the way like i would argue
that that's an investor being a good
business person if they have more
leverage they should get more
positive terms if you have more leverage
you should get more positive terms
so michael why why is this
the thing that so many investors don't
like us as yc partners telling yc
founders why do they hate when we say
this stuff out loud so much they're
allergic to this advice you know i think
that in general investors are allergic
when we tell founders that there might
be situations where their incentives and
the founders incentives are not aligned
perfectly it's yeah it's like a magic
trick we're like telling people how the
magic trick is performed
it's like a faux pas they don't like it
why do they they always tell us to shut
up when we tell people this they always
tell and there's like and and
i think it's also funny because they
also always tell us like hey like
we're funding your companies like you
shouldn't be like you know like telling
the founders not to have high burn yeah
exactly like i pat your back you pat my
back you know
put all this together
and it's like yeah but man we got to put
those founders first and i think that
like
the other thing that's really tricky
and we were talking about this earlier
is that unfortunately founders get
caught up with this math around
default dead default live because
the math they use to pitch their company
to investors is only a subset of the
math they need to run their business
and i think this point is really tricky
like when you're going in and pitching
for a series a or a series b so often
especially in a good economy
you're talking about top line revenue
you're talking about new accounts that
you've opened you're talking about your
month over month growth and often times
you're talking about your head count
your hiring plans slash the execs you've
brought on so on and so forth like
the that's the math that you're putting
front and center
that's the math that investors
especially in good times over focus on
whereas i'd argue when you're running
your company those numbers are important
but there's also your burn rate your
retention
how much your existing customer accounts
are expanding your revenue expansion
over time
those metrics are the ones that
can better help you when you're trying
to figure out how to make sure my
company stays alive and i think this is
where things are tricky is that in many
ways investors are setting
the agenda on what metrics are important
for a company and the investors
are a little biased
like they they have they have a a point
of view that might be not oriented
around keeping the company alive
and you know pg talked about this right
what was pg's line on on this stuff
yeah um he calls this in the blog post
killer cure where he just points out
that
a founder and investor
have completely opposite incentives
where
as an investor with a portfolio of
companies
if you push them all to grow fast and
some of them
successfully grow really fast with a
high burn and thread the needle
and you know become uber or whatever
and some of them completely explode like
fly the plane into the side of the
mountain like fast
and there's lots more fast out there
it actually makes sense from a portfolio
theory to advise people to do this
because either way either it works great
or it dies and goes away and you get to
spend your time on something else but
like either way it's explosive right
it's explosive good explosive bad well
and for a good fund that time is the
limiting factor right not money yeah
and board seats you're limited as a vc
on how many boards you can sit on and so
you don't want to set so so basically if
you're a vc and you sit on a board of a
company
that takes forever to get big
with like low burn
that's kind of boring and kind of bad
for your career and look you look bad to
your colleagues like there's all these
dynamics that founders are not aware of
um that's not a good
move to be on the several boards of
companies doing just okay versus if
you're a founder
and you're choosing between do you want
a zero
literally zero or do you want to keep
going and give yourself more time to
figure out product market fit and maybe
you can figure out an exit and make
life-changing money
yep
then that to a vc doesn't matter at all
like man that sure sounds like misline
incentives right michael like
massively so
sometimes the investor in this equation
is kind of is
perceived by founders who haven't raised
money yet is like
demanding
that the company grows or demanding the
company burns a lot of money
as if they were the boss and i think
this is a very bad misconception like
i don't i think that's extremely rare
for an investor to be demanding you to
like burn like crazy
i think that the horrible truth is that
founders don't need much of a push
oh it's like it's like how michael i
hear you're demanding people to raise at
high valuations
yes
exactly aren't you demanding why i am
i'm i'm i'm i'm twisting their arms to
dilute less it's i'm so powerful
i think this is the tricky bit is that
like
deep down inside every founder wants
permission to blitz scale and that
they're special and they're going to
build the next big one and so if you
talk to you know half a dozen people and
one of them is like yeah i don't know
maybe you should grow faster i don't
know maybe burns on our biggest concern
like that's actually the fly on the wall
recording i wish you could have a reply
on the wall it's like yeah you know
these numbers i think you want to get
these up but i don't know if burns my
biggest concern and then the founder
hears that and they're like we're going
it's time i knew it
what did fast do they raised 100 million
and they burned it in 10 months they got
into a 10 million a month burn
that's incredible
i'm i'm actually super impressed you
have to really try you'd have to be
working pretty hard on it we certainly
need a lot of recruiters
you gotta hire a lot of people
yeah cause like
what else are they spending money on
there's no inventory like if it was a
hardware company i'd understand but
there's no inventory like and it's it's
i assume they weren't getting offices it
was during covid right so it's like
i have no idea i just it's
that takes effort is my point you don't
you don't just wake up one day with a 10
million a month burn
and be like oh you know we're cutting
free stacks
this spinning is out of control in these
stacks we need to
friends tricky
so
there's another concept in
um
this default a live default dead uh
article that was linked to it was
another pg essay called the fatal pinch
i think it's so interesting because we
see this in office hours so frequently
like it is so common that we will
talk to a founder who's in the fatal
pinch and doesn't realize it and it's
funny because at the end of the batch
you tell everything everybody a very
simple concept it's basically
stay lean until you have something and
then spend money on growing it
yet founders
inevitably
get frustrated get tired get distracted
and somehow always come to the
conclusion that spending more money
allows product market fit to happen
faster
and what's sad is that like probably at
least for me more than 50 percent of the
time
i don't get the office hour
before the founders decide to ratchet up
the spend
right as always when it's too late
they're like yes i always get the office
hour when they're down to low runway and
they they're like
we're we're dead we're bleeding out you
know plea please help and it's like if
you would talk to me six months earlier
we could have tied a tourniquet around
your gaping leg wound and you'd be alive
hell we could have saved the lag
what's tricky is that
if you find yourself even suspecting you
could be in this situation
like you need to do this math as soon as
humanly possible right like you're
probably too late to do this math in all
cases and no one wants to do it because
it's too late because it's a buzz kill
man no one like who wants to be that guy
everyone's gonna be mad at you your
investors are gonna be like oh why are
you bringing this stuff up you need to
focus on growth like like i didn't you
know like people will give you a hard
time to bring this stuff up until it's
too late and then everyone's like why
didn't you bring this up earlier to play
devil's advocate though
well we have a bunch of great engineers
at dalton we could always get accu-hired
right
yeah
so
we have the data here at yc
and i will not tell you that
no acquisitions ever happened but
similarly what i was saying earlier
where if you only read techcrunch about
the successful fundraisers it gives you
a warped perspective on how common
they get are successful and that most
series a fundraisers fail well guess
what
no one gets acquired effectively like
there's an asterix next to no one but
the the companies of the companies that
attempt when they're low on runway
they're they're they flew the plane into
the side of the the mountain
there's no acquisition coming man like
i'm sorry like maybe you could get lucky
maybe you built a great team everyone
says that but again like to keep picking
on the fast thing i think a firm
paid them zero dollars i believe to get
all of their engineering talent
what would the incentive have been for a
firm to pay any money for a company
that's rapidly dying there's no market
for a company that's out of money right
anyone that's smart on the buy side
knows that a company that is
hemorrhaging cash will soon be bankrupt
why would you want to buy that problem
you're almost worth less than nothing
because you often have legal liability
and so no one wants to buy problems
and and i think that that's
so unfortunate because once again
if you're sitting at 12 or 18 months of
runway
there's even flexibility on the
acquisition front that doesn't exist
when you're sitting at three to six
months of runway like
you can do all all of the moves that you
can do to rescue your company require
time
so
let's talk about that let's talk about
the moves
what are some of the tough decisions
that you might have to make if you find
yourself default dead
and you want to change that
let's go through the list of pain uh
what's number one
nothing well for most folks it's it's
it's literally head count it's not
office snacks i'm sorry
that's probably not the thing that's you
know perks are not bankrupting the
company it's that you hire too many
folks people are expensive
and this is
80 like i've just seen so many people's
like burn
spreadsheets you know you have two
that's always the thing they want to be
like well but we're very cheap or we're
you know they want to
tell a story but it it's
it's people over hiring is the thing
and i think it's sad
because
no one likes letting people go no one
let's like like let's go letting good
people go right it's it's horrible
the best founders if they have to do
this will make sure that they get other
jobs we'll make sure that they that
they're well and the best thing is to
never over hire to begin with like like
honestly
yes actual hack is to not over hire yes
once we start having that we over hire
now what do we do conversation
let's not have that conversation like
that's like too far so the actual advice
is
don't
make it a problem and then you don't
have to worry about how to fix it
the number two
is ad spend and and man we see this all
the time
it's well
we have this top line goal we need to
hit 80k mri right michael wait we need
to we need to hit 80k mrr we got to hit
it and so we got to spend this much
money on ads in fact we have to spend
more money on ads every month
because we're growing to hit our growth
going yeah
and unfortunately
the result of that is also that like our
payback period for every customer that
we're acquiring
is either super long or long and growing
so our ad dollars are getting
more
ineffective as we are scaling them up
and we have to show growth because if we
if we stop
increasing our ad spend basically if we
stop steering the plane into the
mountain and putting the gas yeah we're
like putting throttle in
if we don't do that we won't raise and
so you'll talk to founders but they know
the problem they're like yeah yeah we're
in trouble we need to raise and we're
like well
maybe don't like don't crash the plane
to the mountain and they're like yeah
yeah but
you don't get it if we don't
put the throttle into the side of the
mountain we won't be able to raise
and it's like these are the most
frightening conversations it's so bad
and i think what they and what they
don't want to do is take the l like they
don't wanna they don't want to
take the growth hit because they they
the the idea that maybe someone would
fund them or maybe they could sell their
company in some long shot scenario
prevents them
from not steering the company in the map
right and i think this isn't talked
about enough like
many successful companies have had to
take l's along the way oh yeah like
learning how to take a punch is not a
bad thing losing face no one cares no
one care oh you reduced your ad spend
your growth evaporated
but you're around to live
to fight for another day that's fine
and then the last one and you brought
this up in previous conversations
raising prices
it's like wow well the thing that we're
selling now money this thing we're
selling a lot of right now we lose money
every time we sell it maybe we could
increase prices so that we are break
even or we make a dollar every time you
sell it oh no
that means we're going to sell it to
fewer people it's like
yes
so our plan is to sell a dollar for 99
cents and it's going well
and we're like well have you considered
not losing money on every transaction
like absolutely not
well how dare you even suggest that you
talk about this a lot like i think it
exercises a different muscle in your
customers brain
when they know they're getting a deal
right it's like like in some weird way
they're willing to use a product that's
like they would never use in any other
circumstance if they know they're
getting a dollar worth of value for 75
cents
well and you see this in new york
recently with uh the 10-minute delivery
stuff there was like eight of them
and you could go get free they all had
coupons
so as a consumer you could like
get a lot of free stuff and that was all
vc subsidized
every time that company is losing money
and
like everything it's a wealth transfer
from investors to consumers yeah i
actually appreciate that you know yeah
it's and to be clear
some of these companies may make it
there maybe one or two
yes but my guess is the ones that make
it are very very very smart about this
stuff i mean yes as per doordash who i
guess we always talk about but you know
they were good at numbers and they they
understood default to live defaulted and
they understood burn like very
sophisticated and so even though they
were pla they were they were flying the
plane very close to the mountain
yes but they were also very aware of the
mountain they knew what they were doing
they were test pilots
versus hey i don't know like i i read in
techcrunch that if the more i burn the
more i raise so i guess look do you see
the difference folks like doing high
risk things when you're sophisticated
and you know the risks
is going to work out better for you
than wishful thinking high risk takers
that never works
not racial yes and so
what's interesting here is this idea
that you know i i
was thinking about this
taking one of these hits right taking a
big hit to your growth rate in order to
get to default to live
it sounds a lot like bankruptcy
it kind of sounds a little bit like
personal bankruptcy where it's like you
take a hit on your credit score to kind
of clear your debts
and the benefit though is you clear your
debt like like you you are now living
sustainably
as opposed to
um unsustainably
now here's why it's better than
bankruptcy i think in a traditional
bankruptcy it takes seven years for your
credit to kind of get repaired
um the startup world works a lot faster
than that
so at any given time in your startup
you're being judged on the last six to
18 months
and so if you take this hit you cut your
revenue in half but you get to default
to live
and the result of that is you get to
spend the next six to 18 months
building a better product getting closer
to product market food or getting
product market fit you're going to be
judged on just that last six to 18
months you're not going to be judged on
when you had
a horrible business that was burning
more money than it was making
structurally
and you're gonna have a huge advantage
and
what's tricky was like this was kind of
our story at justin tv and twitch like
almost exactly like yeah you had the
choice you looked into the precipice you
guys could have jumped in you could have
just let it go like right you could have
let it go so i mean we had raised about
seven or eight million dollars
we had grown to about
i don't know let's say like 30 million
monthly
um
people were watching content
we were making about 750 000 a month in
revenue but we were
we had a million dollars a month in
expenses we were burning 250 000 a month
and i swear to god like
to come to jesus moment was with half a
million bucks in the bank
and i always loved this because like you
know as yc founders we don't talk about
these mistakes and want to give you the
impression that we didn't make them like
we made this exactly we were right there
they taught me this mckinsey and harvard
business like no like you know that's
what's nice about being former founders
is yeah man we got all this [ __ ] wrong
yes like no one's actually
playing right towards the mountain like
straight on like
like deep deep mountain not top mountain
and we i remember we had this meeting
um
with a lot of our employees
and we were like look we got three
options we can die in two months
we can try to get to break even
um
or we can try to get this thing
profitable
and i remember like i had to call this
meeting and it was one of the most
embarrassing things i've ever had to do
up front because i'm just like talking
about admitting defeat i'm like
here's the thing we're gonna die i
messed up you blew it yeah everybody
i'm bad at my job
exactly like raising my hand
i suck at this hey guys i let us astray
yes
and i remember thinking
and i think this is the silver lining i
remember thinking i have no idea whether
everyone's just gonna quit
or whether they're gonna rally
and everyone rallied and it shocked me
but then like i thought about it more
and i was like what kind of person joins
a [ __ ] startup right
it's not the kind of person who's like
well i don't see any risk here like this
seems like smooth sailing all the way
right these are very uh mature
um
veterans
absolutely not right and so you know we
selected for the right people on the
pirate ship right like the pirate ship
they knew they're on a pirate ship um
and i remember everyone was like we are
going to get this thing profitable we
had to do some bad stuff we definitely
had to let go of some people
our version of raising prices we had to
put ads on everything like we put
pre-roll video ads on anything that
moved i remember it was
we had this we literally had this easel
with a big piece of paper on it and i
was like on this side we're going to
write down everything we can do to cut
costs on this side we're going to write
down everything we can do to make more
money and we're not going to leave this
shitty little conference room until
there's a hundred thousand dollars of
revenue somehow a profit here
and what's crazy is that we had that
meeting in august by october we were
break even
by the end of december we generated 1.2
million dollars in profit
and we saved the company and i remember
the feeling of not needing vcs anymore
and that's because that's not the last
time we pitched vcs but just it was the
last time that i feel well it wasn't the
last time
there was a nice little window
where for a second we didn't need vcs to
like us in order for our business to be
alive and like and what's funny man is
that was the moment
you were actually tested and you guys
like you and your co-founders like that
was it
in retro in hindsight
you guys had a choice and you did you
took the l
you took the hard
hard
but now here you are and that was like
really smart and we just see so many
folks
that don't do it
they have that it's like sitting there
in front of them the hard move and they
don't do it for whatever reason
well and what's crazy is the idea for
twitch happened after that and like i it
makes sense in hindsight why like we
were
if you're not just freaked out about
dying all the time
maybe you can apply your brain to like
how to make this thing work i think
sometimes it's okay to do a startup
bankruptcy like sometimes it's okay to
take that l
get to sustainable and figure [ __ ] out
and especially if you've raised
like yeah you see people that raise
and again like let's keep picking on
fast like
they could have just not spent the money
no one forced them to
seven months in they could have stopped
spending the money and they'd still have
a ton of money yeah
and so there's some amount of like
playing along like like there's some
amount of like founder
choosing making a proactive choice to
not course correct because they believe
the fundraising to come in and again
this is the point of pg's blog post
which is don't do that right and
sometimes you know this is what happened
to my startup and this would have this
what happens to the delivery ones is you
have contractual
like lease obligations kill people i had
deals with the music industry and
there's nothing
literally nothing i could do about that
and that sucked you know and so to the
extent you have a startup that doesn't
have contractual requirements to burn
lots of money like we work or something
you know i'd recommend not starting one
of those but if you're in one you should
be really careful of this stuff
yes um well by the way venture dad is
similar
right like i am
like right when you're hurting you got
to start paying more money out
and they can very very similar yeah
so
what's the big takeaway here i think the
takeaway is one
um
before you thrive you have to survive
and
sometimes you're within you know
sometimes you're gonna hit product
market fit in the first 18 months of
your company sometimes you're not
and if you're running your company
default to live you're giving yourself
enough time to figure out product market
fit
and man sometimes you're getting a
product market if it's complicated and
you're not losing sleep
about the macro environment think about
how many founders right now are sweating
bullets watching the stock market
and watching interest rates and i don't
blame them right like i'm not saying
that's wrong but the default life
founders are kind of like eh
whereas the ones who know they need to
raise soon
there's they're work there's they they
ask a lot of questions and i get where
it's coming from but they seem nervous
i think the second big takeaway here is
that
investors are not going to twist your
arm to burn
but you should also be careful to not
react to the slightest suggestion that
burning more might be okay
like unfortunately or fortunately you're
in control here
and like if someone whispers to you oh
maybe you should slam that
slam that airplane into the mountain
that's not like that doesn't mean that
you're not the pilot holding onto the
stick and you can control where the
airplane's going like they're gonna be
fine
and you're gonna be fine yeah this is
the thing this is what's so weird about
this business is like
who has to live with the rest of their
lives
that that was their startup
or that they could have done something
different they weren't able to versus
the investors like yeah whatever cool
and they go you know they don't think
about it at all ever again and then
maybe the last take away here is that if
you if you are in an operationally
intensive business you know a lot
doordash you better be
10x better than the people around you at
knowing your numbers
at steering that plane well yeah the ceo
the founders have to be
pushing for this not the board not the
vps not your cfo
founders have to care about this and i'd
argue this is one of the dirty little
secrets behind amazon they've always
known that they were in a low margin
business
and they've always run their company
that way and i'm sure they were so
tempted to look at a google or a
facebook and say why don't we do those
things
and like they had to be strong enough to
say because we're not in ridiculous
high margin businesses like they are
like we're going to play our game
anything i missed dalton any other final
takeaways
i think you got it i mean i think
anyone who's anyone out there who's
stressed about raising the next round
this is just a helpful reminder you
should read the blog post you do the
math but
you don't have to be
as stressed out if your default alive it
actually completely changes it's like a
weight is lifted off your shoulders it's
crazy because you don't yeah
you're not hoping that some stranger
somewhere is going to bail you out it's
a bad feeling but when you're in control
you feel you feel much better so i'd
recommend it
all right great chatting dalton
thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you